Disney has actually admitted that the
movies they are producing the politics
contained do not align with the public
in an SEC filing they're telling their
investors our bottom line is at risk
because of the political nature of the
content we produced ladies and gentlemen
I want you to all Revel in the victories
of watching this company get well go
broke and there's there's so much more
to this because uh uh joining us tonight
we've got Jeremy boring the daily wire
just put out a trailer for their new
film lady ballers
and it's fascinating to see the success
the rising growth of those who oppose
the wokeness and the weird culty stuff
in media and the failures at the exact
same time but we have a really great
example of this because it's not just
lady Ballers the daily wire announces
Snow White what happens what a week
later Snow White from Disney which got
rid of the dwarves and is going with the
politically correct companions is sheld
they're pushing it way back